i have a comment this one's from
professor edward lee of berkeley and it
may provide some insight and you both
can tell us your thoughts on this so
this is from professor edward lee of
berkeley this question is a major theme
in the second half of my book plato and
the nerd utms so universal turing
machines have the following properties
number one their operation is a sequence
of discrete steps number two the data
comes from a countable set number three
that sequence terminates it is a huge
leap of faith to assume that physical
processes have any of these constraints
i show in plato and the nerd that the
hypothesis that physical processes all
have these properties is actually
untestable i remember earlier yosha you
mentioned that
if it's untestable and you can't provide
evidence for it then perhaps it
shouldn't be talked about so this
reminded me of this and he says in
brackets this follows from an
information theorem due to clochen and
known as the channel capacity theorem
the converse hypothesis that the
physical world is not so constrained is
also untestable by experiment but i
argue in plato and the nerd that the
converse hypothesis leads to simpler
models of the universe and therefore is
a better choice by outcomes razor my
claim is that universal turing machines
is realized on today's computers are
simulations quote unquote of a process
that is fundamentally non-algorithmic so
i just want to place that out there and
perhaps you can use that as a jumping
off board donald and then yosha
very interesting i'll want to read that
book and make sure i understand what
what uh professor lee is saying this is
quite interesting so plato and the nerd
um
i'll be interviewing edward at some
point in the next few weeks as well
oh well very good yeah that's that's
that's really quick because these are
very very
deep issues it seems to me that this
also interacts with what the physicists
are telling us that there is
no time fundamentally
so so if if time is not fundamental then
these computational issues where there
are
fundamental limits to what can be
computed because we're assuming time
a sequence of so in in computer
simulations computer algorithms
we're assuming
a sequence in time of computations that
can be and the kinds of limits that
yoshi's talking about
seems to me
are a consequence of assuming time to be
fundamental and if we have to go to a
physics in which time is not fundamental
then that that places this whole our
whole conversation in a completely
different context
and and and so
what we may be pointing to is
time has
been a very useful and helpful thing for
physics for several centuries and and
now the hard work that we have to do is
to understand how to go beyond the
notion of time and when we go beyond the
notion of time well the kind of
discussion we're having
right now be fundamentally revised um
the computational versus
non-computational notions we may have to
really
revise how our whole conversation here
is going i'd be very interested what
yoshi has to say on that
thank you also thanks edward lee for
your
argument
i
concur with you that it's in principle
not testable what physics is really like
what we can only say is which theory
that we can come up with is more elegant
but uh i
as a small thing i i think that this
notion that the turing machine has to
get a result after a finite sequence of
steps
uh may be a mistake in the sense in
which two machines were originally
defined
so uh basically uh a computer that can
be built is not a turing machine in this
sense but it's always a finite state
machine
and in a finite state machine you can
have a number of steps a sequence of
steps that is unbounded that doesn't
stop and that gives you more and more
digits of pi while you're looking at in
a sense uh it doesn't come to a
conclusion if you want to compute
physics but it's not the problem to
build a computer that as long as it runs
gives you more digits of pi and so i
think from a formal perspective or from
an uh it doesn't make much of a
difference because you can easily fix it
but it's important uh if you think about
your intuitions about how things work or
the proofs that you make in other
contexts
that the
value of computation doesn't hinge on
there being a finite
number of steps until a computation that
is going to give you a result that was
formulated classical mathematics
terminates but that it means that
everything that you get is the result of
finite interactions
and if you assume that infinite
interactions are possible you run into
the difficulties that goodell and turing
has have discovered which means that
your theories no longer work they no
longer make sense and different from
edward and maybe doing him injustice
here i haven't read this book
so
i would say that it's much more elegant
from the perspective overcomes razer to
describe reality in a language that
doesn't break
because if your language breaks and you
still try to make a
model of reality it's going to be
arbitrarily expensive it doesn't work
you have to find a language that works
so if we find that the languages in
which we can describe reality have to be
computational languages because the
others lead into contradictions then we
have to use the computational languages
that's the situation that i find myself
to be in this doesn't mean that i can
know what physics is like it just means
that all the physics that i can talk
about without my language breaking
has to play out in this way
and the notion of what is time so coming
back to donald is is very important that
the two notions of time one is this
intuitive notion that we have as human
beings which is um basically this
newtonian time this time which uh where
clocks run the same speed everywhere and
so on and that describes the transition
of the universe from the past into the
future via the present
and
this notion of time is somewhat similar
to the notion of the straight state
transition in your computer
except that the state transition in a
computer has some kind of global clock
where everything in the computer goes
from state to state all at once and goes
progresses to the next step but what we
see in our universe that it only makes
sense if we assume that it's dynamic
if the universe would just be a
decoupled sequence of states without a
transition function there would not be
any law that we can discover there is
nothing that we can control organisms
would not exist in the way in which they
do so we from the observations that we
make we have to assume that the
transitions in the universe are somehow
fundamental that the universe is moving
and state transitions seem to be crucial
in order to be able to understand the
universe but there is some notion of
transition and this notion of transition
is much more basic than time
and the time that we are talking about
when we see that time is not fundamental
in the notion of space time is
relativistic time
the relativistic time is what the
universe looks like to a relativistic
observer and we can obtain relativistic
time if we understand that
what we perceive as time is basically
the speed of the clocks in our
environment
and the speed of the clocks that we
observe depend on our own speed
so if i move you through the universe
and you are a supervening pattern on the
structure of the universe imagine the
universe is something like an ocean
and the present is the crest of a
traveling wave through that ocean
and uh there are
uh waves maybe in front and behind us
but they're not our future the past
they're different universes that just
happen to be a little more along a bit
less along the future and past would
require you to leave the crest of the
wave and you can't because you're always
traveling with the wave
so there is no way to leave that present
because only the present exists from the
perspective of that crest and you or me
we are vortices and scribed on the crest
of that traveling wave
and the
rotation that the vortex is doing when
it updates itself to observe the
universe to form a memory and so on and
to register its perceptions and so on
will depend on the speed in which this
vortex rotates
right
and so if the vortex is moving along
with the wave then the updates in the
vortex are a function of the movement in
the wave itself the basic parasites on
the movement of the main wave
and you can not as this vortex traveling
with the wave ever leave the wave you
can move a little bit in this in the
wave to the left or to the right
that is moving to the left or the right
would be movement in space you cannot
move in time you just move this the time
right and the faster you move to the
left or to the right the less there will
be updates available for in turning your
internal state
so the fluctuations of the vortex
becomes slower and slower the more the
vortex moves in space and this leads to
relativistic time it means that from the
perspective
of the vortex when it looks at its
environment the environment gets
distorted in time in space
so in this notion we realize why
something would look like to a vertex
that moves like this
like relativistic time and we understand
that the relativistic time from the
fundamental perspective how to make all
this happening how to build a system
that functions like this cannot be
fundamental
it's a result to the observer it will be
what the universe looks like to the
observer of the observer screens as we
always do
right but it is not fundamental but
fundamental are the state transitions
so what we need to do is basically
replace the physical as time that is
relativistic for good reason in the
frame of certain models by something
that is more fundamental and allows us
to derive the relativistic time and this
would be state transitions
very very interesting there's some
in that spirit um or at least in that
kind of direction there's work by
marcus mueller and and phillippone
and and then also some some more recent
work um
by fabio mercadi and um
and giovanni emelino camilla
where where they're
showing how relativistic space times can
be
constructed
from exchange of quantum information so
you don't assume it up front but you try
to get a dictionary
to that allows
different
quantum
agents to send information back and
forth and it turns out if you send
enough information back and forth um and
try to set up a dictionary to make
everything consistent you will get
einstein's
special relativistic um space time
coming out of it so that's that that's
that's
an interesting direction
to go
um another
interesting direction
to think about one just a simple notion
time and entropy
least physical time and entropy are
deeply connected
and so we would like to have
some way of getting entropic time coming
out of
a deeper system in which there is no
entropic time right
and there there is a
i'm not saying this is the deepest way
of doing it but an interesting simple
way just in the case of markovian
dynamics so if i have a
a markovian system
um
homogeneous
and it's in the stationary
then the entropy of that system doesn't
change
so
if if
for state x sub n and xn minus 1 and so
forth the entropy h of x of n
equals h of x sub n minus 1 for all n
so you so there is no entropic time
but
it's trivial to prove
that if you just do a simple
conditioning if i if i look at xn given
x1
or x yeah xn given but then it turns out
that
h of xn
given x1 is greater than or equal to h
of x n given x n minus 1. in other words
the very fact of in
doing conditioning which is projection
so you can think about
i take this
dynamical system which has a notion of
state transition that's a markov chain
but it doesn't have any entropic time
but as soon as you start projecting that
that non-entropic system onto different
perspectives by
by conditioning like h of x n given x1
all of a sudden now you have entropy
and so now you have that kind of notion
of time so so is that a direction that
we could go
where where we could still have
in some sense a dynamical system but
it's not an entropic time system
and and show how we get space time
arising from that in the way that you
know some of these businesses are trying
to do i i think that will be
be interesting i think that it's a
separate question whether the real
numbers exist versus right that's
it's a it's a pretty strong statement to
say that real numbers don't exist that's
that's really quite interesting
to say that they don't exist
but i guess that that's where you want
to go anyway
yeah well i agree with pythagoras that
real numbers don't exist
and the time was not right back then so
real numbers are actually functions
and you can can give you this function
instead of a real number and it can give
you as many digits as you want unless
you can afford to compute but this is it
it's fine so basically real numbers
can be derived in a deterministic
fashion they are determined once they
are predetermined in the sense
but
you will not know the billions digit of
the square root of two unless you find a
procedure to compute it and
the energy
for the neck entropy
to
actually get there and this derivation
of
a result via using upnic entropy i think
relates to our perception of time this
causal error of time which is aligned
with the entropic arrow
eric drescher finds a very good metaphor
in his book good and real i think to
give an intuition how a symmetric system
where the transitions are symmetric in
both directions
it's still uh not going to be um
symmetric at scale when you look at it
so it takes as an example a well that is
made of large and small billiard balls
and did you put one of these billiard
balls in motion and uh the transaction
between the ball is also magical which
means if you take a movie and you play
it forward and backward
you will see for the every interaction
between two billiard balls that it's the
same if you go the movie backwards or
forwards it's a simplified model where
you have no friction
and so we have no thermodynamic uh stuff
going on we look at the universe at the
level where thermodynamics doesn't exist
yet because this maybe the staff is too
small to have these losses right so we
just look at the billiard ball universe
where everything is deterministic and uh
without noise
and in this model what we see is that
when we zoom out there is something that
is happening
um at scale and that is
some balls
move after they have been hit and keep
moving hitting other balls
and there are if you play the movie
backwards it looks as if some balls are
anticipating that they are going to be
soon hit and start moving
uh as a result as if they would be hit
right so there is this asymmetry that uh
your balls leave a wake
behind them
and uh this vague
is describing in some sense the entropy
that we are looking at in our universe
that's the direction in which you can as
an embedded observer for memories
because in order to form memories you
rely on the dissipation of information
between locations
and so whenever
there is a way to form memories it means
that you are aligned with some kind of
entropic arrow
if you zoom out it means that you can
now sort the states of the universe in
such a way that you discover the
concentric wave that you are that you
are part of in our
ocean like universe
has a point of origin
and this point of origin is a
construction that you make you discover
this by the wave expanding and you
discover it by information
moving diffusing across the locations in
the wave
so there is a hypothetical point
in the middle
where the information is not diffused
yet
and this hypothetical point is what we
imagine to be the big bang
right and it's a mathematical
singularity in a way because if you are
in the big bang you don't know which
direction to go unless the big bang is
not completely perfect and symmetrical
and the interesting thing about this
before the big bang
means uh it's it's the wrong question to
ask because before the big bang if you
it looked like it is like a more rape
pattern this would be the point where
the information goes out of a
distribution or gets distributed or
diffuses being locations in the other
direction every point
every trajectory that goes away from the
big bang goes into a future sorry to
interrupt is this related to the janus
point
have you heard of julian barber's theory
of time
no
no but it's a it's an artifact of a
certain disruption basically we create a
certain mental model in which we
describe the
entropic error of time as the diffusion
of information across locations in the
universe and then we imagine that there
is a single point where this ends up and
we go through this point on the other
side we go back into another future
so so the further we go away from this
point in any direction the further we go
into a future in which systems could
form memories of the past and to form
memories of the past you need to have
some kind of reservoir of neck entropy
that you can tap and some kind of puddle
of neck entropy and then you can reason
about the conditions
how such puddles of neck entropy could
form under which conditions and how long
they might last
you